okay
it's probably up there with some of the
most incredible stunt work I've ever
done the things that you think would be
green screen just practical
it's really exciting when you get actors
that want to put that effort in we've
been doing some wildlife
it's like an Uber violence that goes to
such a Zone you can't help but be
shocked
we're doing a lot of blood a lot of Gore
we have this wonderfully gory effect
Dracula disappears into the priest
you know when something crazy happens
it's definitely and anything goes movie
and someone's like I've seen any worse
it was a proper Sprint but it definitely
paid off everything I saw you do today
is going to be my way worse